listen now you have bragging rights for
your son
like listen to me son i'm in a marvel
movie you just back off yeah but here's
the thing my son's nine months old
doesn't matter so i'm like but i was
thinking this i was like by the time
he's old enough to recognize his father
was in a marvel movie it's seriously
retro
you know everything will look out of
date
he's gonna look like king kong from 76
like dad those graphics were so outdated
the sad father going i was in a marvel
movie
once
one of those times but see there you go
you have a little bit of a legacy it is
kind of cool though like when he gets a
little older to be able to sit down and
say look at this i've heard the actors
children
are just not impressed that their
parents are actors they're like it's
really uncool yeah get ready to be there
i want them to think that your job's
cool but they're like no get ready for
eye rolls and really dads yeah yeah
exactly
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
you've you've done a lot game of thrones
of course was so huge but when you turn
this corner and you see that hollywood
boulevard is shut down do you have a
moment like what i was saying i was like
this is big this is a big old carpet i
think it might be the biggest carpet
i've been on
and i've been fortunate to be on some
big ones in my time it's huge they don't
they don't mess around no marvel doesn't
mess around not at all we love the mcu
we love all the movies that come with it
so is it an immediate yes when you get
the call about this or was it like
chloe's owl's vision as well that said
okay yeah this is going to be really
interesting it's interesting that term
get the call isn't it because it did
feel like that you get a call saying
right well marvel are calling you're
like okay and you you know you i your
eyes kind of light up and your ears
prick up and you go all right well
i hope it's something or someone or i
hope it's good because
i'd really like to say yes to it
and then um so i then met with chloe and
discussed
and already even before nomad land i
think she's a pretty formidable director
so all of those things and the character
that i'm playing
is interesting that's all i can really
say
man i know everyone's giving like one
word little nuggets i'm like i gotta get
in here and see this have you seen the
movie i have seen the movie okay and are
we are we ready for what we're about to
see yeah i think so i think it's i think
it's a marvel movie that fits the age
angelina said chloe describes it as a
love letter to the earth yeah that's a
good that's a that's i hadn't heard that
chloe called it that that's an
interesting way of looking at it i think
it's
i think it's fitting of our time is how
i'd put it you know it feels like it's
got some stuff to say and put put down
as markers